o lado pessoal aqui quem fala é o dar
que sejam muito bem vindos já mais de um
vídeo e o estrago de que um vídeo muito
a somar aos detrás do que gravar the
dream model's problema já não sei como é
que se chama o jogo mas é um jogo de 180
gravar com o único picape com o guaxinim
o vídeo ficou brutal pessoal por isso
vamos ficar aqui com os melhores - diz
vídeo desse jogo não sai passem pelos
canais deus contar na descrição da china
possa foi também e só espero que vocês
gostem flec favorito e e já foi
convidado daqui eu já convivi vai
quebrar a cara de cidades não chove
o show se encontrar cara fala que é
gamer enem
acho que no jogo ou procurar a jogo
eu quero ser aguentou eu sou rico pela o
dele
quero jogar no ataque que o fantasma
acho que fui submetido é o daer baixar o
volume de extrema
a tim o youtube chegou na mesa de
mistura tem que ter calma produto agora
vai explicar em outubro ganhas por
sublinhar esta pessoa boa que ele
poderia por exemplo se você dentária a
serventuária conectados
outras latinas - eu não consiga maroto
custo está morno na rocha
o tom roxo vino sou eu que até embaixo
de mim eu falei eu eu vou lá pra cima e
já há a já teve já se criou nada
não não estiver tudo isso nos faria
morreu no último jogo né comenta o
advogado da nato que isso ia dar sim eu
quero ir embora
chega no ei no q1 é no q2
está a trabalhar num plano que vocês
estão já tô ouvindo passo que a você que
droga para superar o ano
ai eu posso abrir as portas a reforma e
não como um negócio xadrez gigante que
13 bruxo [ __ ] não consiga lidar ano
espero marcar mais um
vamos combinar um encontro que tomar um
café é procurar ele regimental não
enquanto cantava do novo mundo que aqui
é ganhar e foi pra ele acha o relógio
a a8
agora sou eu e s vamos por aqui amigos
vamos todos juntos no round
durante o vôo o piloto não conseguindo
não é visível que não conseguir somar os
dois primeiros golos do paok obrigado
por me ter dito agora espera ter o
ecotudo jesus e judas pelo ppd/psd uma
clara declaração lado de ciro foi uma
pessoal ter uma cultur olha aí não não
isto estes túmulos né não paga para onde
a bola é sobre maio
não não
o socorro rui esteves estocar assumiu o
fantasma foi ignorado
ele está lindo maravilhoso jogar junto
com o amigo e agora quer que eu faça
chover pra você só assiste também que
bom que coloca uma pessoa ruim né
assistindo você está sua mãe tudo título
nó real reconhece que o ic6 olha olha no
meu olho no chão muito suja uma equipe
ele para um banheiro que só isso fala
mesmo ser roubado é o fábio do time do
fantasma
como é que eu tô lá andam ali mesmo
dentro aí já não tinha ninguém aqui olha
aí não faz ninguém gosta que um armário
22 filhos também a eleição clone zebuíno
nelo furto não era ciclone favorece o
fogo
o jogador segundo e é sério é não e isso
foi muito entusiasmado com a china já
estava morto
pensava nada é família também percebeu a
mãe
[Música]
o
ae
[Música]